Cosmic girl is back at Spaceport
Cornwall but the rocket she launched is
lost forever
the mission had started so well lifting
off from Newquay airport under her Wing
the launcher won rocket carrying nine
satellites
then over the Atlantic the rocket
released fired its engine and powered
away towards space it looks to be a
successful ignition but 30 minutes later
back came the message new key we have a
problem
welcome back everyone uh it appears that
launcher one has suffered an anomaly
which will prevent us from making orbit
for this mission
the Virgin orbit is trying to work out
what happened but the Spaceport proved
Rockets can be launched from a regional
airport one part of it didn't go to plan
but that hurts everybody but at the same
time we're a licensed Spaceport we show
that we can launch and that's just so
exciting for us because we know and
we're ready to do it again and we've
learned so much from the experience and
we'll Implement that into the to the
next time that we go and hopefully that
will be you know soon launcher one has
two sections the main first stage has an
engine that takes the rocket to an
altitude of around 50 miles it then
falls back to Earth while a second stage
engine ignites lifting the payload of
satellites to more than 100 miles the
engine then cuts out with the Rockets
still climbing fast it's at this point
that something went wrong the rocket
only reached 11 000 miles an hour well
sure to the speed needed to put the
satellites in orbit
NASA and SpaceX make rocket launchers
look easy but many of their early
missions also failed success comes from
learning what went wrong re-engineering
and going again
on board the rocket was a prototype for
a space Factory insurance covers the
loss but not the months of work that
went into the design
nothing short of Devastation
it was a real big moment for the team
launching our first mission four star
zero as well as the first satellite
design built in Wales but at the same
time we still have a lot to celebrate
we got here we got wales's first
satellite to a launch pad
this would have been the first satellite
launch in Europe a commercial coup for
the UK space industry
and while the rocket may have fallen
back to Earth the ambition remains Sky
High
Thomas More Sky News in Newquay